Цей університет займає таку велику площу
в берлінському районі Далем,
що на його честь назвали станцію метро.
Заснований 1948-го року
Вільний університет Берліна за кількістю студентів
– перший серед вишів столиці Німеччини.
Одна зі студенток - 24-річна
Маргарита Давиденко з Одеси.
Вона навчається на факультеті економіки за спеціальністю менеджмент
і маркетинг.
За її словами, підхід до навчання в Німеччині
помітно відрізняється від українського.
Тебе вчать думати по-іншому.
Тобто якщо в нас існує правильна або неправильна відповідь,
то тут ти можеш сказати "так, це добре"
або "так, це погано", але ти повинна це обґрунтувати.
Тобто аргументація - для мене це було на початку трохи складно.
У Вільному університеті навчаються 180 українців.
Загалом у німецьких вузах, за даними 2016-го року,
майже 7 тисяч українських студентів.
Україна посідає шосте місце серед країн світу
за кількістю студентів у Німеччині
- після Китаю, Туреччини, Австрії, Індії та Росії.
У Вільному університеті це відігравало важливу роль,
тому що університет створювали після війни
і тут велике значення надавали міжнародним зв’язкам,
і, наскільки мені відомо, вже у 1950-х роках
приїжджали перші студенти за обміном з Америки…
І в мене на факультеті на третій семестр
заплановане навчання за кордоном.
Як розповідає керівник міжнародного відділу
Вільного університету,
студентів з-за кордону приваблює перш за все сам Берлін,
а крім того - бездоганний імідж вишу,
який посідає стабільно високі сходинки у національних
та міжнародних рейтингах.
У самому університеті надають
величезного значення міжнародній співпраці.
Це важливо з різних причин.
На рівні студентів це важливо,
бо ми хочемо досягти "інтернаціоналізації вдома",
щоб не варитися у власному соку,
а бути сучасним глобізованим університетом
i переймати досвід з усього світу.
І особливо важливо це у царині спільних досліджень.
Тому що ми впевнені - дослідницька робота тільки виграє,
якщо в ній задіяні міжнародні партнери.
Загалом українські студенти зараховані
до 150 університетів і вищих шкіл Німеччини.
Найбільше їх вчаться
у Франкфуртському університеті імені Ґете.
На другому місці за популярністю серед українців -
університет Людвіґа-Максиміліана в Мюнхені.
На третьому - Гамбурзький університет.
Що ж до спеціальностей, то спектр зацікавлень
надзвичайно широкий: від філософії
та педагогіки до медицини, фізики та інформатики.